This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Every town or city has its own regional celebrity who everyone recognizes. Maybe that person is a high school athlete who made it to the major leagues. Maybe they're a titan of industry. Maybe they're a flamboyant attorney with an excessive amount of billboard ads. Something wrong? Call Anne Fong. Some of them become so successful that their acclaim spreads around the world. And sometimes not. Here to tell us about one of her own favorite local celebrities is actress, reporter, and
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。每个城镇都有自己的地方名人，大家都认得他们。也许这个人是打进美国职业棒球大联盟的高中运动员。也许他们是工业巨头。也许他们是一位拥有大量广告牌的浮夸律师。遇到麻烦了？打给安妮·方。他们中的一些人非常成功，以至于名声远扬世界各地。有时却并非如此。今天为我们讲述她最喜欢的一个地方名人的是演员、记者兼
friend of the show, Gillian Jacobs. Hey Gillian! Hi Roman! It's so delightful to have you here. I'm delighted as well. It's my favorite place to be. So Gillian, you reached out to us because you wanted to talk about a very specific, famous face that you saw all over your hometown. Yes, so I come from the great city of Pittsburgh, also known as Pixberg to locals, and there was a guy who was so famous there that I thought everyone knew his name,
节目老朋友吉莉安·雅各布斯。嗨，吉莉安！嗨，罗曼！很高兴你能来到这里。我也很高兴。这是我最喜欢待的地方。那么，吉莉安，你联系我们是因为你想谈谈一个非常特别、你经常在家乡各处看到的熟悉面孔。是的，我来自伟大的匹兹堡，当地人也叫它 Pixberg，那里有一个人非常有名，以至于我以为所有人都知道他的名字，
and it turns out that's not quite the case. So who is this mysterious local celebrity? I'm gonna leave you in suspense for a little bit longer. So just to back up and explain, this guy recently popped into my head because a few months ago, I was at home watching a football game, which is not common practice for me, read Taylor Swift. But as I was watching the game,
结果证明并非完全如此。那么这位神秘的地方名人是谁呢？我先卖个关子。回想一下并解释一下，这个人最近突然闯入我的脑海，因为几个月前，我在家里看橄榄球比赛，这对我来说并不常见，参考泰勒·斯威夫特。但在我看比赛时，
I noticed that one of the players had something on his helmet. It was this little round green sticker. And I was thinking, why am I drawn to this little green circular sticker on the back of his head? And staring at it unleashed this voice in my head. Mr. Yuck is me. Mr. Yuck is me. Mr. Yuck is green.
我注意到其中一个球员的头盔上有个东西。是一个小圆绿贴纸。我在想，为什么我会被他脑后这个小圆形绿贴纸吸引呢？盯着它看，脑海中突然浮现出一个声音。呕吐先生就是我。呕吐先生就是我。呕吐先生是绿色的。
Mr. Yuck. I thought that the football player was wearing a Mr. Yuck sticker, and it turns out I was not even close. That sticker means that a player is allowed to communicate with the sidelines via a radio in his helmet, but It still sent me down this deep rabbit hole of why Mr Yuck was so deeply embedded into my psyche that I was seeing him on the back of a football player's head Why indeed why indeed have you ever heard of mr. Yuck? I have I am familiar with mr Yuck because he showed up briefly on this episode that we did years and years ago.
呕吐先生。我以为那个橄榄球运动员贴了一个“呕吐先生”的贴纸，结果我猜得十万八千里远。那个贴纸的意思是，允许球员通过头盔里的对讲机与场边交流，但这还是让我陷入了一个深深的疑问：为什么“呕吐先生”会如此深地烙印在我的脑海里，以至于我在一个橄榄球运动员的脑后看到了他？确实如此，为什么呢？你听说过“呕吐先生”吗？听说过。我很熟悉“呕吐先生”，因为他在我们多年前做的一期节目里短暂出现过。
But I also recognize him because I was a kid alive in the Midwest in the 1980s, central Ohio for me. But for people who are not Midwestern Gen Xers, who is Mr. Yuck? Mr. Yuck is a neon green circular sticker with a cartoon face on it. His face is scrunched up with his eyes squeezed tight and his tongue is sticking out of its
但我认出他也是因为我是20世纪80年代在中西部长大的孩子，对我来说是俄亥俄州中部。但对于不是中西部 X 世代的人来说，“呕吐先生”是谁？“呕吐先生”是一个带有卡通脸的荧光绿圆形贴纸。他的脸挤成一团，眼睛紧闭，舌头伸在
mouth. It's the face you make when you taste something disgusting. Yeah, he's the pictorial embodiment of the sentiment of yuck. Right. He's a symbol for hazardous substances aimed at deterring children from ingesting them. He was basically created to indicate that if you saw a Mr. Yuck sticker on something, it meant that that something was poison. Do not ingest.
嘴外面。这就是你尝到难吃东西时做出的表情。是的，他就是“恶心”这种情绪的具象化。没错。他是旨在阻止儿童吞食有害物质的危险品标志。他的创立基本上是为了表明，如果你在某个东西上看到“呕吐先生”的贴纸，就意味着那个东西有毒。切勿吞食。
And I grew up thinking he was as famous as Smokey Bear. Right. And if I remember correctly, parents would get these sheets of the Mr. Yuck stickers and stick them on dangerous stuff like drain cleaner or whatever a kid could get his hands on underneath the sink. Exactly. So Mr. Yuck was created in 1971 by a physician named Dr. Richard Moriarty, who was a pediatrician and the founder
我从小就以为他和森林王子烟煤熊一样出名。没错。如果我没记错的话，家长们会拿到这些“呕吐先生”的贴纸，把它们贴在危险物品上，比如管道疏通剂或者小孩子在水槽底下能触及的任何东西。完全正确。所以“呕吐先生”是在1971年由一位名叫理查德·莫里亚蒂的医生创建的，他是一位儿科医生，也是
of the Pittsburgh Poison Center. And as the head of the Pittsburgh Poison Center, he wanted to accomplish two different things. One, he wanted to prevent kids from ingesting potentially dangerous substances. And two, he wanted to teach parents that when their kids did ingest a potentially dangerous substance to call a poison control center before rushing
匹兹堡中毒控制中心的创始人。作为匹兹堡中毒控制中心的负责人，他想完成两件不同的事情。第一，他想防止儿童吞食潜在危险物质；第二，他想教导父母，当孩子吞食潜在危险物质时，在将他们送往医院之前，先打电话给中毒控制中心。
them to a hospital. Because there was a good chance that the kid would be just fine, and calling poison control could save you a lot of time and money. Right, and just generally save taxpayer money too. Yes. So, Roman, in your tenure as a parent, have you ever had to call poison control? Thankfully, no. No. Not with any of my children. But I have always been fascinated by the poison control hotline, because basically it's this type of very low ambition,
因为很大几率孩子会安然无恙，而打给中毒控制中心可以为你节省大量时间和金钱。没错，总体上也能为纳税人省钱。是的。那么，罗曼，在你为人父母的期间，你有没有打过中毒控制中心？谢天谢地，没有。没有。我的孩子们都没有。但我一直对中毒控制中心的求助热线很着迷，因为基本上这是一种非常低调的、
free healthcare service that you can call anytime for a very specific kind of medical advice. And so I've always wondered how that came to be. Well, Roman, you are a very lucky man because I'm here to tell you. So poison centers are actually a pretty recent phenomenon. Until the 19th century, we mostly had to rely on conspicuous packaging and poison labels
免费医疗服务，你可以随时打电话获取非常具体的医疗建议。所以我一直很好奇这是怎么来的。嗯，罗曼，你是一个非常幸运的人，因为我来告诉你。所以中毒中心其实是一个相当晚近的现象。直到19世纪，我们在预防中毒方面主要还得依靠醒目的包装和毒药标签。
for poison prevention. Apothecaries were required to store hazardous substances in irregularly shaped bottles so they wouldn't be mixed up with the other products. And also in the mid 1800s, it became mandated by the American Pharmaceutical Association to clearly label a bottle with the word poison or with the medically accepted poison symbol at the time.
药剂师被要求将有害物质存放在形状不规则的瓶子里，这样它们就不会与其他产品混淆。此外，在19世纪中叶，美国药剂师协会强制规定，必须在瓶子上清楚地标明“毒药”字样或当时医学界接受的毒药符号。
And that poison symbol being the skull and crossbones. You got it. But by the time we rolled around to the end of the 19th and early 20th century there actually still wasn't a ton else being done in terms of preventative poison control, which was a huge problem because around then a brand new danger was entering American homes. Mr. Clean gets rid of dirt and grime in just a minute. Mr. Clean will clean your whole house and everything that's in it. Floors, doors, all the time.
那个毒药符号就是骷髅和交叉骨。答对了。但到了19世纪末和20世纪初，在预防中毒控制方面其实仍然没有做太多其他事情，这是一个巨大的问题，因为大约在那个时候，一个崭新的危险正在进入美国家庭。清洁先生在一分钟内就能除掉污垢和油污。清洁先生会清洁你整座房子和里面的一切。地板、门，无时无刻。
Ah yes, the dastardly Mr. Clean, the worst of all. Now I don't want to blame everything on Mr. Clean, especially because he actually wasn't invented at this time. But he and other package cleaners represented this huge cultural shift taking place in the early 1900s. There was really an explosion of consumer product marketing and production.
啊，是的，可恶的清洁先生，最糟糕的一个。现在我不想把一切都怪在清洁先生头上，尤其是因为他其实不是在这个时候被发明的。但他和其他包装清洁剂代表了20世纪初发生的巨大文化转变。消费品营销和生产确实出现了大爆发。
And there were all sorts of products that were coming on the market like vacuum cleaners, but also household cleaners that were pre-prepared and packaged. This is Dr. Marion Moser-Jones. She's an associate professor and historian of public health at Ohio State University. She says that at the turn of the 20th century there was this whole chemical revolution taking place in the United States. In the early 1900s Americans developed a kind of obsession with cleanliness and hygiene. There was also a huge rise in
市场上涌现出各种各样的产品，比如吸尘器，还有预先包装好的家用清洁剂。这位是玛丽昂·莫瑟-琼斯博士。她是俄亥俄州立大学的副教授兼公共卫生历史学家。她说，在20世纪之交，美国正在发生一场轰轰烈烈的化学革命。在20世纪初，美国人对清洁和卫生产生了一种痴迷。
mass production and advertising which meant more of these pre-packaged cleaners ended up in homes around the US. So suddenly, whereas before it might have been that in an average household there might have been some lye soap or a couple of potential poisonous substances, now there were all of these packaged cleaners. You had a floor cleaner or floor polish. But most of these products being marketed were not being labeled correctly. So this was very prevalent in turn of the 20th century U.S. society. These substances, these products that were mislabeled, and there wasn't really a requirement to label them.
大规模生产和广告也出现了巨大增长，这意味着更多这种预包装清洁剂最终进入了美国家庭。所以突然之间，以前在一个普通家庭里可能只有一些碱性肥皂或几种潜在的有毒物质，现在却有了所有这些包装好的清洁剂。你有了地板清洁剂或地板抛光剂。但当时推销的大多数产品都没有被正确贴标签。这在20世纪初的美国社会非常普遍。这些物质，这些贴错标签的产品，而且当时并没有真正要求给它们贴标签。
And certainly if you were manufacturing some kind of product, I mean, why would you put a giant warning sign on it if all of your competitors are not? I can remember and I lived through a time when there was a wonderful slogan called, better living through chemistry. And consumers demanded household conveniences. And at least some of these chemicals and some of these products were toxic. And so who is this? This is Dr. Alan Wolf and he wears many many impressive hats and two of them are
当然，如果你在制造某种产品，我的意思是，如果你的所有竞争对手都没有这样做，你为什么要在上面贴一个巨大的警告标志呢？我记得，而且我经历过这样一个时代，当时有一个很棒的口号叫“通过化学获得更好的生活”。消费者对便利家居生活有需求。而且至少其中一些化学品和一些产品是有毒的。那么这是谁？这位是艾伦·沃尔夫博士，他身兼数职且个个令人印象深刻，其中两个是
pediatrician and the co-director of the Pediatric Environmental Health Center at Boston Children's Hospital. He says that these new cleaning products were made up of incredibly dangerous and toxic chemicals. And because chemical companies really resisted proper warning label regulation, it was children in particular who were the big victims of accidental poisonings during this time. Kind of post-World War II and the baby boomer generation, a lot of infants, and then toddlers came of age in the late 1940s and early 1950s. The peak age of poisoning is somewhere between one and three years of age. That rise of dangerous household substances wasn't limited to cleaning products either.
波士顿儿童医院儿科环境健康中心的儿科医生兼联合主任。他说，这些新的清洁产品由极其危险和有毒的化学物质组成。由于化学公司极力抵制适当的警告标签法规，儿童特别成为了这一时期意外中毒的主要受害者。在二战后和婴儿潮一代时期，许多婴儿和蹒跚学步的幼儿在20世纪40年代末和50年代初长大成人。中毒的高峰年龄在1岁到3岁之间。危险家用物质的增加也不仅限于清洁产品。
Around the 1940s, the pharmaceutical industry came out with a marketing scheme that probably at the time sounded like a great idea, but was actually terrible in execution. Candy aspirin. I'm old enough, Gillian, to remember taking candy aspirin. And it was just that. It was orange-flavored tablets and very attractive to children. Ah, yes. Let's make potentially dangerous medications synonymous with candy. orange-flavored tablets and very attractive to children.
大约在20世纪40年代，制药行业推出了一种营销计划，在当时听起来可能是一个绝妙的主意，但在执行时却糟糕透顶。糖果阿司匹林。吉莉安，我年纪够大，还记得吃过糖果阿司匹林。事实就是如此。那是橙味药片，对小孩子极具吸引力。啊，是的。让我们把潜在危险的药物变成糖果的同义词。橙味药片，对小孩子极具吸引力。
Ah yes, let's make potentially dangerous medications synonymous with candy. What could possibly go wrong? Right? Not so fun fact. Within three years of candy aspirin debuting, preschool aged children represented 80% of aspirin deaths. That is horrifying.
啊，是的。让我们把潜在危险的药物变成糖果的同义词。怎么可能会出岔子呢？对吧？一个不太好笑的事实。在糖果阿司匹林问世后的三年内，学龄前儿童占了阿司匹林死亡人数的80%。这太可怕了。
I know. So there's this influx of dangerous products in homes, most of which are not labeled correctly. And on top of that, if a child got into one of those toxins, many doctors didn't even know what or how much of those products would be lethal if ingested by children. No one could keep all this in their head. You know, what's the toxicity of the little things that you find in new shoe boxes that are supposed to keep the shoes dry, the little silica packets? Are they poisonous? Are mothballs poisonous? Nobody could keep that all in their head. So Lewis had the great idea of filling out little
我知道。因此，家里涌入了大量危险产品，其中大部分都没有正确贴标签。最重要的是，如果孩子接触到其中一种毒素，许多甚至不知道如果被儿童吞食，哪些产品会致命，或者多少剂量会致命。没有人能把所有这些都记在脑子里。你知道，你在新鞋盒里找到的用来保持鞋子干燥的小东西，即那些小硅胶包，它们的毒性如何？樟脑丸有毒吗？没有人能把这些全部记住。所以刘易斯想出了一个好主意，那就是填写小小的
three-by-five cards. So that Lewis was Lewis Godalman, the man who developed the first poison control center. He was a pharmacist in Chicago at St. Luke's Hospital and he saw this issue of a lack of information on poisonings and decided to do something about it. He started collecting information on poisonous substances and filling it on these little index cards. He ended up accumulating information on roughly 9,000 different substances. And by the 1950s, he was the go-to poison expert.
三乘五英寸卡片。这个刘易斯就是刘易斯·戈达尔曼，他是开发第一个中毒控制中心的人。他是芝加哥圣卢克医院的一名药剂师，他看到了缺乏中毒信息的问题，并决定采取行动。他开始收集有关有毒物质的信息，并将其填写在这些小索引卡上。他最终收集了大约9,000种不同物质的信息。到了20世纪50年代，他成了首屈一指的中毒专家。
And he sort of organized an informal referral service that people recognized him as an expert who was interested and could talk to these families and talk to health care providers about what the poisonings were and how they should be managed. Physicians at St. Luke's Hospital, where he worked, started consulting with Godalman, and then word spread to other hospitals in Chicago, and eventually to other cities. Godalman would personally answer calls at any time,
他组织了一种非正式的转诊服务，人们公认他是一位感兴趣的专家，可以与这些家庭交谈，并与医护人员讨论中毒情况以及应该如何处理。他工作的圣卢克医院的医生开始向戈达尔曼咨询，然后消息传到了芝加哥的其他医院，最终传到了其他城市。戈达尔曼会亲自在任何时间接听电话，
day or night, from his home, but it's really hard to be a one-man band slash encyclopedia brown of poisons. So eventually Goodalman, along with Dr. Edward Press, founded the first poison control center in the United States in 1953. So that was the background for the start of the poison control movement in the United States. After that, poison control centers started taking off like gangbusters.
无论白天还是黑夜，从他家里接听，但要当一个单打独斗的硬汉兼中毒界的百科全书全才真的很难。所以最终，戈达尔曼与爱德华·普雷斯博士一起，于1953年在美国创立了第一个中毒控制中心。这就是美国中毒控制运动兴起的背景。在那之后，中毒控制中心开始如雨后春笋般蓬勃发展。
There was a huge number of centers opening up across the country throughout the 1960s. It kind of became a marketing technique for your local hospital. Like we have such high standards at our hospital, we have a poison control center. So in the 1960s, that really took hold so that by the mid 60s to late 60s, there were over 600 poison centers in the United States. But see, the problem with this influx of poison control centers was that the quality of care
在整个20世纪60年代，全国各地涌现出大量的中心。它有点成为当地医院的一种营销手段。就像我们的医院标准很高，我们有一个中毒控制中心。所以在20世纪60年代，这真的流行起来，以至于到60年代中期到60年代末，美国有600多个中毒中心。但是看，这种涌入的中毒中心的问题在于，各中毒中心之间的护理质量
between the poison centers really could be inconsistent. Some of them covered a neighborhood, a few thousand people. Others covered millions of people. Some of them were staffed by secretaries or pediatric and family practice, healthcare providers or trainees, whoever. So there was a lot of variability and there were complaints.
实际上可能参差不齐。其中一些服务于一个社区、几千人。另一些则服务数百万人。其中一些由秘书或儿科和家庭执业的医护人员或实习生等人 staffing（配备人员）。因此存在很大的变异性，也有很多抱怨。
These were hard to reach. They weren't adequately staffed. They weren't adequately publicized. And the information they gave was variable. And this disjointed approach to poison centers was a really dangerous problem. Dr. Wolf actually worked as a poison center operator, and he says that it's a really high stress environment.
这些很难联系到。它们人员配备不足。它们宣传不足。它们提供的信息变化多端。这种对中毒控制中心不连贯的方法是一个非常危险的问题。沃尔夫博士实际上曾在中毒控制中心担任接线员，他说这是一个压力极大的环境。
When I was in the poison control center and talking to a parent and they are saying, center operator and he says that it's a really high stress environment. When I was in the poison control center and talking to a parent and they are saying my child just swallowed floor wax and so you had to you know I had to juggle the microfiche reader and put in what the floor wax contained and then when you found out the detergents you had to flip that out and flip in the other kind of management Microfish reader meanwhile the parent is holding online He told me one story that really illustrated how important it was to have reliable care at these centers I remember a call I got at 7 a.m. One morning of two workers In Massachusetts who were found down at change of shift
当我还在中毒控制中心的时候，跟一个父母通话，他们说，中心接线员，他说这是一个压力极大的环境。当我在中毒控制中心和一个父母通话，他们说我的孩子刚刚吞下了地板蜡，所以你必须，你知道，我必须一边操作缩微胶卷阅读器，输入地板蜡包含的成分，然后当你发现去污剂时，你必须把那个翻过去，换上另一种处理方式缩微胶卷阅读器，同时父母还在线上。他告诉我一个故事，真正说明了在这些中心拥有可靠护理是多么重要。我记得有天早上7点我接到一个电话，是马萨诸塞州的两个工人，在换班时被发现倒下。
So these two men had been working in a chemical plant and were found down at change of shift. So these two men had been working in a chemical plant and were found unconscious. Their job was to stir this sludge that was actually toxic discharge and they weren't wearing protective gear. And unfortunately, this particular sludge contained a substance called propionitrile,
所以这两个人在一家化工厂工作，在换班时被发现倒下了。所以这两个人在一家化工厂工作，被发现时已经失去知觉。他们的工作是搅拌实际上是有毒排放物的污泥，而且他们没有穿防护装备。不幸的是，这种特殊的污泥包含一种叫做丙腈的物质，
which when you inhale it, it's turned into cyanide. So they were both suffering from cyanide poisoning. Oh my god. I know. It's horrific. But luckily, in this case, Dr. Wolf, who is a trained specialist, was there to answer the call. We recommended giving the cyanide antidote kit very
当你吸入它时，它会转化为氰化物。所以他们两个都遭受了氰化物中毒。天哪。我知道。太可怕了。但幸运的是，在这种情况下，经过专业培训的沃尔夫博士当时在那里接听了电话。我们建议非常迅速地使用氰化物解毒剂盒，
quickly, and they were saved. So in a situation like that, you really need someone who's highly trained to answer your call, which at the time, I mean, is kind of a roll of the dice because there's 600 different call centers with varying degrees of reliability. Yes, and this was one of the big problems that Dr. Richard Moriarty, the father of Mr. Yuck, wanted to solve in 1971. He wanted to find a way to make sure parents had the information of a trusted poison control center if their child ingested anything dangerous. Dr. Moriarty actually passed away in 2023,
他们得救了。所以在这种情况下，你真的需要一个训练有素的人来接听你的电话，这在当时，我的意思是，有点像掷骰子，因为有600个不同的呼叫中心，可靠性程度各不相同。是的，这也是理查德·莫里亚蒂博士（“呕吐先生”之父）在1971年想要解决的重大问题之一。他想找到一种方法，确保如果孩子吞食了任何危险的东西，父母能够获得值得信赖的中毒控制中心的信息。莫里亚蒂博士于2023年去世，
but this is a clip from an interview he did a few years before he died. We needed to get out the word that there was a for real poison center, for real people that were there 24 hours a day, seven days a week. And they sort of knew what they were doing. And if you had a problem, give us a buzz. So we had to get our phone number out to the world. On top of the lack of knowledge around reliable poison centers, like the one he was running, Dr.
但这是他去世前几年接受的一次采访的片段。我们需要让人们知道，有一个真正的中毒中心，有真正的人在那里全天候24小时、一周7天工作。他们对自己在做什么略知一二。如果你有问题，给我们打个电话。所以我们必须把我们的电话号码传遍世界。除了缺乏关于可靠中毒控制中心的知识（比如他当时运营的那家），莫里亚蒂博士
Moriarty realized that there was a very unique problem that impacted the children of Pittsburgh specifically. Oh, what is that? So as you remember, the medically accepted warning symbol for poison since the 1800s was the skull and crossbones, right? Well, in Pittsburgh, that symbol carries a different connotation for kids. The traditional warning symbol was the skull and crossbones, which just happened to be part of the logo for the Pittsburgh Pirates and still is. Okay. And I thought, you know,
意识到有一个非常独特的问题专门影响匹兹堡的儿童。哦，那是什么？正如你所记得的，自19世纪以来医学界接受的毒药警告符号是骷髅和交叉骨，对吧？嗯，在匹兹堡，这个符号对孩子们来说有着不同的含义。传统的警告符号是骷髅和交叉骨，而这恰好是匹兹堡海盗队标志的一部分，现在依然是。好的。我想，你知道，
that doesn't make a whole heck of a lot of sense. Oh my God, that's so true. Yeah. You know, we love our sports in Pittsburgh. You know, so the Pittsburgh Pirates, this is huge for us. And there's a perhaps apocryphal story that the children of Pittsburgh would see a skull and crossbones image and rather than think dangerous, poisonous, I must stay away, they would think, oh, my beloved baseball team, you know, maybe this bottle of Windex is a Pittsburgh Pirates beverage. So Dr. Moriarty had the idea to create a brand new symbol that would both spread awareness of the Pittsburgh Poison
这根本说不通。天哪，太对了。是的。你知道，我们在匹兹堡热爱我们的运动。你知道，所以匹兹堡海盗队，这对我们来说意义重大。有一个也许是杜撰的故事说，匹兹堡的孩子们看到骷髅和交叉骨的图像，非但不会认为危险、有毒、我必须远离，反而会想，哦，我喜爱的棒球队，你知道，也许这瓶威露士清洁剂是匹兹堡海盗队的饮料。所以莫里亚蒂博士萌生了一个想法，要创造一个全新的符号，既能传播对匹兹堡中毒
Center and was original and free from any other associations, one that would only and strictly mean do not eat. He wanted something akin to Smokey Bear or McGroth the Crime Dog, anthropomorphized PSA. And Dr. Moriarty believed that for this symbol to be effective with children, they needed to engage with them in the design process. And so he worked with a PR firm to pull together a focus group of kids. We started off basically with sort of preschool age kids and said to them, if you got into a poison, what would happen to you? And the recurring answers were, you die, you get sick,
中心的认知，又是原创的且没有任何其他联系，一个将只严格意味着“请勿食用”的符号。他想要类似于烟煤熊或警犬麦格劳那样的人格化公共服务广告。莫里亚蒂博士认为，要让这个符号对儿童有效，他们需要在设计过程中让儿童参与进来。因此，他与一家公关公司合作，召集了一个由儿童组成的焦点小组。我们基本上从学龄前儿童开始，对他们说，如果你误服了毒药，你会怎么样？反复出现的回答是，你会死，你会生病，
your mother would yell at you, okay? And we thought those are all pretty good things. Accurate things. Good answer. So Moriarty worked with a guy named Dick Garber of the PR firm Vic Maitland and Associates, and they interviewed children five and under and used their answers to come up with the design of the face and the color of the sticker. And this is the Mr. Yuck sticker that
你妈妈会冲你吼，好吧？我们觉得这些都挺不错的。准确的事情。好回答。因此，莫里亚蒂与一家名为 Vic Maitland and Associates 的公关公司的迪克·加伯合作，他们采访了五岁及以下的儿童，并根据他们的回答设计了面部表情和贴纸的颜色。这就是那个
you thought erroneously was on the back of a football player's helmet, the sort of the squinty face, the tongue, and it's like this bright fluorescent green. Exactly. So the thought process behind the color was which color will children like the least? Which color will they be repelled by? Clearly the color stuck with me. I think I'm seeing it every time I see a green circle. So they presented children with several colors to choose from and the consensus was that they liked the fluorescent green the least.
你误以为在橄榄球运动员头盔背面的“呕吐先生”贴纸，那种眯着眼睛、吐着舌头的表情，而且是这种亮眼的荧光绿。完全正确。这种颜色的背后的思考过程是，孩子们最不喜欢哪种颜色？他们会排斥哪种颜色？显然，这个颜色深深地印在了我的脑海里。我想我每次看到绿色圆圈都会看到它。因此，他们向孩子们展示了几种颜色供选择，共识是他们最不喜欢荧光绿。
And while they did use a graphic designer to come up with the initial sketches, when it came to the final design, this is my favorite part, they held a contest for kids via the Pittsburgh Poison Control Center and a fourth grader from West Virginia named Wendy Brown designed the logo and won the contest. Oh go for it Wendy! We tried to track her down for this story. We could not find her but Wendy if you're listening, congratulations. So they
虽然他们确实请了一位平面设计师来做最初的草图，但在最终设计方面，这是我最喜欢的部分，他们通过匹兹堡中毒控制中心为孩子们举办了一场比赛，来自西弗吉尼亚州的一名四年级学生温迪·布朗设计了这个标志并赢得了比赛。哦，加油，温迪！我们试图在这个故事中追踪她的下落。我们找不到她，但温迪，如果你在听，恭喜你。所以他们
had the design and the color, but they still needed a catchy name. We all know how important names are, right? So they went back to the kids and they showed them the sick face in fluorescent green. And one kid said, he looks yucky. And that was a mic drop moment. You got your name, Mr. Yuck. Out of the mouth of babes. Literally. In the words of Dr. Moriarty, the skull and crossbones were designed by adults for adults.
有了设计和颜色，但他们仍然需要一个引人注目的名字。我们都知道名字有多重要，对吧？所以他们回到孩子们身边，向他们展示了荧光绿的恶心面孔。其中一个孩子说，他看起来很恶心（yucky）。那是一个高潮迭起的时刻。你得到了你的名字，“呕吐先生”。童言无忌。字面意思。用莫里亚蒂博士的话来说，骷髅和交叉骨是由成年人为成年人设计的。
Mr. Yuck is actually the first symbol specifically designed for kids. I mean, creating a symbol for young children is really an interesting design challenge because a good portion of your audience doesn't even know how to read. so it has to be something very literal, very memorable, and very easy to understand. Right. So how popular did the Mr. Yuck program end up getting? So the Pittsburgh Poison Center mailed many many sheets of
“呕吐先生”实际上是第一个专门为儿童设计的符号。我的意思是，为幼儿创造一个符号确实是一个有趣的设计挑战，因为你的大部分受众甚至不识字。所以它必须是非常字面化、非常令人难忘且非常容易理解的东西。没错。那么“呕吐先生”项目最终变得多受欢迎？所以匹兹堡中毒控制中心向宾夕法尼亚州及其他地区的家庭邮寄了许多
the stickers to households around Pennsylvania and beyond which definitely got the word out. But Mr. Yuck really took off in 1975 after a PSA ran during the 1975 Super Bowl. Now there's a man whose face is green that you ought to get to know. He'll warn you when danger's coming fast or slow. Get to know his face in every single place. Parents like my mom dutifully slap them onto bottles, spray cans, medications, yada, yada, yada. And for kids like myself, Mr. Yuck
贴纸，这确实把消息传开了。但“呕吐先生”在1975年超级碗期间播放了一则公共服务广告后真正腾飞了。现在有一个脸是绿色的男人，你应该去认识他。当危险迅速或缓慢逼近时，他会警告你。在每一个地方认识他的脸。像我妈妈这样的父母尽职尽责地把它们贴在瓶子、喷雾罐、药物上，等等等等。对于像我这样的孩子，“呕吐先生”
was a daily household presence. My mom even put one on our home phone. Well, she's contributing to the semiotic drift here, Gillian. No, no. This was actually encouraged by the Poison Control Center so that you would always have the number at hand at the ready. She wasn't suggesting that the phone was poisonous and that you were going to eat it or something.
是日常家庭中的存在。我妈妈甚至把它贴在了我们家的电话上。嗯，这在这里是在助长符号学漂移啊，吉莉安。不，不。中毒控制中心其实鼓励这样做，这样你随时都能手头备有这个号码。她并不是暗示电话是有毒的，你打算吃掉它什么的。
She was worried about a lot of things in my childhood. I don't think that was one of them. Usage of Mr. Yuck actually did spread slightly beyond Pittsburgh, but it never became the ubiquitous national symbol for poison control centers. Why do you think that is? I think one part of it was that initially Dr. Moriarty would only send the stickers to hospitals who agreed to participate in his Pittsburgh Poison Center program. And this required that the Pittsburgh Poison Center would be the central hub and all the
她对我的童年有很多担心。我觉得那不是其中之一。“呕吐先生”的使用实际上确实稍微传播到了匹兹堡以外的地方，但它从未成为中毒控制中心无处不在的全国统一符号。你认为这是为什么？我认为其中一部分原因最初是莫里亚蒂博士只把贴纸寄给同意参与他的匹兹堡中毒控制中心项目的医院。这要求匹兹堡中毒控制中心作为中央枢纽，所有的
other centers would have to report back to them. Okay. And you know, I think some other cities and regions want to do their own thing. A lot of hospitals saw it as a way to create attention for their local poison control center. And some of them even created rival mascots. Mr. Yuck's biggest competition was Officer Ug, who was a cartoon cop with his hands over his mouth. He also came with his own theme song, I'll have you know. I'm Officer Ug. My name is Officer Ug. Remember never to touch, boys and girls as such. When
其他中心都必须向他们汇报。好的。你知道，我认为其他一些城市和地区想做他们自己的事情。许多医院认为这是为当地中毒控制中心吸引注意力的一种方式。他们甚至创造了自己的竞争吉祥物。“呕吐先生”最大的竞争对手是“乌格警官”（Officer Ug），这是一个双手捂着嘴的卡通警察。你知道吗，他甚至还有自己的主题曲。我是乌格警官。我的名字叫乌格警官。记住永远不要去摸，各位男孩女孩。当
you see Officer Ug, certain things... What the hell is that? It doesn't even make any sense. It does not. The children aren't Officer Ugg. Why are they saying I'm Officer Ugg? I don't get it. I don't get it at all.
你看到乌格警官，某些事情……这到底是什么鬼？这根本说不通。确实不通。孩子们不是乌格警官。为什么他们说我是乌格警官？我不明白。我完全不明白。
Too cute. I want my poison control mascot to scare the crap out of me. That wasn't even the end of it. There were other rival mascots like NoSciOp the Snake. What? Do you get it, Roman? NoSciopTheSnake. What? Do you get it, Roman? NoSciopTheSnake.
太可爱了。我希望我的中毒控制吉祥物能把我吓个半死。这甚至还没完。还有其他竞争对手的吉祥物，比如蛇诺西奥普（NoSciop）。什么？你懂吗，罗曼？蛇诺西奥普。什么？你懂吗，罗曼？蛇诺西奥普。
No. Oh, I'm sorry. NoSciop is poison spelled backwards. I thought that would be obvious to you. There was also PinkyTheElephant. Huh. And my favorite, Uncle Barf. Well, Uncle Barf, I could see that one working.
不。哦，对不起。NoSciop就是毒药（poison）倒过来拼写。我以为这对你来说是显而易见的。还有一个叫“平基大象”（PinkyTheElephant）。哈。还有我最喜欢的，“呕吐大叔”（Uncle Barf）。嗯，“呕吐大叔”，我能看出那个行得通。
That is a good name. Yeah. We all had an Uncle Barf. I know. that one working. That is a good name. Yeah, we all had an Uncle Barf. I know. I actually think that one still has legs. Maybe it's not too late. Internet, do your thing. So as you can see, this disjointed, uncoordinated approach meant Mr. Yuck wasn't as recognized in most parts of the US.
那是个好名字。是的。我们都有一个呕吐大叔。我知道。那个行得通。那是个好名字。是的，我们都有一个呕吐大叔。我知道。我其实觉得那个现在还有潜力。也许还不算太晚。互联网，显露你们的身手吧。如你所见，这种支离破碎、缺乏协调的方法意味着“呕吐先生”在美国大部分地区并没有得到那么高的认可度。
And this war of the poison control mascots kind of illustrated the problem with poison control centers across the country at the time because there still was no single coordinated poison control agency. So then what happened to Mr. Yuck? By the 1980s and 90s, the number of poison control centers started to decline and then in the early 2000s, Congress passed the Poison Control Center Enhancement and Awareness Act which allocated support to poison centers. So now 100% of the US population is served by just a single toll-free phone number from anywhere in the country which is great but it also
这场中毒控制吉祥物的战争某种程度上说明了当时全国各地中毒控制中心存在的问题，因为当时仍然没有一个单一、协调的中毒控制机构。那“呕吐先生”后来怎么了？到了20世纪80年代和90年代，中毒控制中心的数量开始下降，然后在2000年代初，国会通过了《中毒控制中心增强和意识法案》，为中毒中心分配了支持。所以现在全美100%的人口都可以通过全国任何地方的单一免费电话号码获得服务，这很棒，但这也
means that Mr. Yuck wasn't relevant anymore because people didn't need to be directed to the Pittsburgh poison centers number. So basically because we means that Mr. Yuck wasn't relevant anymore because people didn't need to be directed to the Pittsburgh Poison Center's number. So basically because we have one single national poison control number, Mr. Yuck just wasn't really useful anymore. Exactly. The Pittsburgh Poison Center does still distribute stickers for fun, but they now have the national poison control number, which is 1-800-222-1222. Oh, I'll also side note that
意味着“呕吐先生”不再相关了，因为人们不再需要被指引到匹兹堡中毒中心的号码。所以基本上因为我们意味着“呕吐先生”不再相关了，因为人们不再需要被指引到匹兹堡中毒中心的号码。所以基本上因为我们拥有一个单一的全国中毒控制号码，“呕吐先生”真的不再有用了。完全正确。匹兹堡中毒控制中心仍然为了好玩分发贴纸，但他们现在有了全国中毒控制号码，即1-800-222-1222。哦，我还要顺便提一下，
when the national number was established, there was a push to adopt Mr. Yuck as the national symbol, but it was rejected in favor of, do you know Roman? I mean, was it the skull and crossbones again? Close, but no cigar. It's a red pill bottle with a white skull and crossbones. I mean, it's fine. It's fine, but it's not iconic, like Mr. Yuck, in my opinion. I mean, well, the problem with skull and crossbones is it is iconic, but it's iconic for a lot of different reasons. Like, it's cool looking.
当全国号码设立时，曾有人推动采用“呕吐先生”作为全国符号，但它被拒绝了，转而采用了，你知道吗，罗曼？我的意思是，又是骷髅和交叉骨吗？接近了，但没中。那是一个带有白色骷髅和交叉骨的红色药瓶。我的意思是，这还可以。这还可以，但在我看来，它不像“呕吐先生”那样具有标志性。我的意思是，好吧，骷髅和交叉骨的问题在于它确实具有标志性，但它是出于许多不同的原因才具有标志性的。比如，它看起来很酷。
It's like cool for pirates, you know? It's just not all poison anymore. But I guess what I'm curious about is if the Mr. Yuck branding Really worked like did it actually reduce childhood accidental poisonings in and around the Pittsburgh area at least so mr Yuck launched in 1971 and within just a couple of years rates of childhood poisoning actually began plummeting Wow Okay. Yeah, but not because of Mr. Yuck. Mr. Yuck is great for educational purposes and awareness,
海盗觉得它很酷，你知道吗？它不再只是代表毒药了。但我好奇的是，“呕吐先生”的品牌推广是否真的起作用了？它是否确实减少了匹兹堡及周边地区的儿童意外中毒事件？所以“呕吐先生”于1971年推出，在短短几年内，儿童中毒率实际上开始直线下降。哇，好吧。是的，但不是因为“呕吐先生”。“呕吐先生”对于教育目的和意识提升非常棒，
but you really need to prevent the kid who's really determined to get into that bottle. I mean, a three-year-old or a four-year-old has little impulse control and a lot of curiosity. And so I've had one three-year-old, a four-year-old before, and so I know this. They may not be deterred by any kind of symbol. They're deterred by packaging that prevents them from getting into the actual package.
但你真的需要阻止那个决心去拿那个瓶子的孩子。我的意思是，三岁或四岁的孩子几乎没有冲动控制能力，却有着很强的好奇心。所以我也带过一个三岁、一个四岁的孩子，所以我知道这一点。他们可能不会被任何种类的符号吓退。真正能阻止他们的是那种能防止他们接触到实际包装的包装。
That was Dr. Moser Jones again. And she says that in 1970, Congress passed the Poison Prevention Packaging Act, which mandated child-resistant packaging. In the intervening years, child poisoning deaths have fallen by roughly 73 percent, and they have stayed low ever since. By 1981, childhood poisoning death rates had fallen to 25 percent of their 1961 levels. And since 1972, childhood poisoning death rates have not gone back up. So this
这位又是莫瑟-琼斯博士。她说，1970年，国会通过了《防止儿童中毒包装法》，强制实行儿童安全包装。在随后的几年里，儿童中毒死亡人数下降了大约73%，并且从那以后一直保持在低位。到1981年，儿童中毒死亡率已经下降到1961年水平的25%。自1972年以来，儿童中毒死亡率就没有再回升过。所以这
has saved lives, this kind of packaging and this enforcement, although some people may criticize it as being the nanny state. It has saved lives. I mean, children need a nanny, right? They do. They totally do. This is not an example of the nanny state. I mean, children need a nanny, right? They do, they totally do. This is not an example of the nanny state. I mean, this is huge. Better packaging, better public awareness, quality access to poison control centers
挽救了生命，这种包装和这种执法，尽管有些人可能会批评它是保姆国家（nanny state）。它挽救了生命。我的意思是，孩子们需要一个保姆，对吧？他们需要。他们完全需要。这根本不是保姆国家的例子。我的意思是，孩子们需要一个保姆，对吧？他们需要，他们完全需要。这根本不是保姆国家的例子。我的意思是，这意义重大。更好的包装、更好的公众意识、优质的中毒控制中心服务
combined to like reduce the number in extremely meaningful way. They stop these kids from getting sick or dying from household poisons. It's amazing. Yes, and I also have to mention that some have questioned the effectiveness of Mr. Yuck. Some studies found that the symbol didn't deter children, and in fact, some kids were
结合起来，以极其显着的方式减少了数量。它们阻止了这些孩子因家庭毒物而生病或死亡。太棒了。是的，我还必须提到，有些人质疑“呕吐先生”的有效性。一些研究发现，这个符号并没有吓退儿童，事实上，一些孩子
actually drawn to ingesting harmful substances because of Mr. Yuck. What's funny is that I do remember the Mr. Yuck stickers. So Dr. Moser-Jones actually grew up with Mr. Yuck as a kid in St. Louis. The thing that stuck with me most was that in our basement, my mother had this old bottle, it was actually a jug with a skull and crossbones on it. And that was much more impactful than Mr. Yuck stickers. And again, I mean, I grew up in a time
反而因为“呕吐先生”而被吸引去吞食有害物质。有趣的是，我确实记得“呕吐先生”的贴纸。所以莫瑟-琼斯博士小时候在圣路易斯确实和“呕吐先生”一起长大。最让我印象深刻的是，在我们地下室里，我妈妈有一个旧瓶子，实际上是一个上面画着骷髅和交叉骨的罐子。那个比“呕吐先生”的贴纸更有冲击力。再说一次，我的意思是，我在这样一个时代长大，
where there were these characters like Oscar the Grouch and Sesame Street, who was sort of a yucky character. I mean, he lived in the trash. He sang these songs about being dirty. And so they were kind of these kind of dirty and yucky characters were somewhat appealing. And so I do think that there is a problem when you have a sticker that could be appealing to kids as well and not just scary. I mean, this is a problem for all symbols. I mean, just like, you know, kids and people
当时有《芝麻街》里的奥斯卡（Oscar the Grouch）这样的角色，他算是一个有点恶心的角色。我的意思是，他住在垃圾里。他唱着关于变脏的歌。所以这些有点脏兮兮、恶心的角色在某种程度上有一定的吸引力。所以我确实认为，当你的贴纸对孩子们也具有吸引力而不仅仅是可怕的时候，就会出现问题。我的意思是，这对所有符号来说都是个问题。我的意思是，就像，你知道，孩子们和人们
just have their own opinions about what a symbol means and it always shifts. Yes. And you know what? I don't want to sell Mr. Yuck short at all. I love the guy. You know, it was a campaign that spread a lot of important awareness about the poison control system. So Mr. Yuck may not have been the hero of the poison control movement, but he was definitely a hero in Pittsburgh. Indeed. Well, thank you so much, Gillian, for bringing us the complete history of Mr. Yuck. I had such a fun time talking with you. My absolute pleasure.
对符号的含义有他们自己的看法，而且它总是在变。是的。你知道吗？我一点也不想贬低“呕吐先生”。我很喜欢这个家伙。你知道，这是一场传播了大量关于中毒控制系统的重要意识的运动。所以“呕吐先生”可能不是中毒控制运动的英雄，但他绝对是匹兹堡的英雄。确实。好的，非常感谢吉莉安为我们带来“呕吐先生”的完整历史。和你聊天非常开心。我的荣幸。
After the break, we revisit a classic 99PI story about warning labels, shared language, and radioactive cats. Stay with us. Ever since this next story first aired back in 2014, it has been a crowd favorite. We thought we'd share it with you again because it features an appearance from a certain mean, green, pictorial embodiment of the word yuck. Enjoy. Matthew Keelty I want to start with a letter. This is reporter Matthew Keelty.
休息过后，我们将重温一个关于警告标签、共同语言和放射性猫的经典 99PI 故事。请继续收听。自从这个接下来的故事在2014年首次播出以来，它一直深受大众喜爱。我们觉得应该再次与大家分享，因为它出现了某个意味着“恶心”的、刻薄、绿色、具象化符号的身影。尽情享受吧。马修·基尔蒂我想从一封信开始。我是记者马修·基尔蒂。
This is a letter that got sent out to a couple hundred people back in 1990. So Roman, if you have the letter and don't mind. Dear so and so, the safe disposal of nuclear waste is one of the most pressing issues facing the United States today. It totally is. But if you actually, if you skip down past that, there's, I mean, that's just about how there's these people who are planning on burying a bunch of nuclear waste out in the New Mexico desert at this place called the Waste Isolation Pilot Plant. But if you go down like another paragraph.
这是一封在1990年左右寄给几百人的信。所以罗曼，如果你有这封信并且不介意的话。致某某，核废料的安全处置是当今美国面临的最紧迫问题之一。确实如此。但如果你真的，如果你跳过那部分往下看，我的意思是，那只是关于有一群人计划把一堆核废料埋在新墨西哥州的沙漠里，在一个叫“核废料隔离试验田”（WIPP）的地方。但如果你再往下看大约一个段落。
You have been nominated to participate in a study sponsored by Sandia National Laboratories that will identify what kinds of markers should be placed at the WIPP site. Just jump down a little bit further. should be placed at the WIPP site. To develop a marker system that will remain operational during the performance period of the site. Ten thousand years. This is John Lomburg. He received one of these letters, which makes sense given his line of work.
你被提名参与一项由桑迪亚国家实验室赞助的研究，该研究将确定应该在WIPP现场放置什么样的标记。再往下跳一点。应该在WIPP现场放置。以开发一个在现场性能期内能够持续运行的标记系统。一万年。这位是约翰·隆伯格。他收到了这样一封信，考虑到他的工作性质，这很合情合理。
I'm an artist and I work on projects involving unusual communication problems. The dude spent time in the 70s working with Carl Sagan and Andrewian on the Voyager Golden record. One of NASA's attempts at communicating with aliens. So you'd think this sort of thing would be right in his wheelhouse. You know, usually you don't get asked to design something that's going to last 10,000 years. That's twice the span of recorded human history. The federal government really was calling on him to help protect people 10,000 years in the future.
我是一名艺术家，我从事涉及异常通信问题的项目。这家伙在70年代曾与卡尔·萨根和安德鲁里安一起参与“旅行者号金唱片”的项目。这是美国萨斯与外星人沟通的尝试之一。所以你会觉得这种事正好切合他的专长。你知道，通常你不会被要求设计一个能保存一万年的东西。那是已记录的人类历史的两倍跨度。联邦政府确实在召唤他去协助保护一万年后的未来人类。
The Waste Isolation Pilot Plant, WIPP, or WIP for short, was ordered into existence by Congress in 1979. The thinking was, the US ought to have a safe place to put radioactive byproducts from nuclear weapons manufacturing and nuclear power plants. And a quick refresher, even though you don't see radiation, and you might not feel its effects right away, exposure to radioactive materials can destroy your body at a molecular level. It can leave burns, it can cause cancer, it can even mutate your DNA. And the thing about radioactivity is that it is very spreadable. Say you've got a tool that touched a piece of plutonium, now that tool is radioactive. And say a worker was wearing protective gloves while using that tool,
废物隔离试点工厂，简称WIPP或WIP，是国会在1979年下令建立的。当时的构想是，美国应该有一个安全的地方来放置核武器制造和核电厂产生的放射性副产品。简单复习一下，尽管你看不见辐射，也可能不会马上感受到它的影响，但接触放射性物质会在分子水平上摧毁你的身体。它会导致灼伤、癌症，甚至使你的DNA发生突变。而且辐射的一个特点是它极易扩散。比方说，你有一个工具碰过一块钚，现在那个工具就具有放射性了。再比方说，有个工人在使用该工具时戴着防护手套，
chances are those gloves are radioactive too. The Waste Isolation Pilot Plant was designed to store all of this stuff and keep us all safe from it. The WIP site is in New Mexico, deep in the desert, about 26 miles east of Carlsbad. It's a really cool place. It reminded me of kind of the headquarters of Spectre or Dr. No in a James Bond novel. Because it's this big underground facility filled with technicians and coveralls, and it's all color-coded depending on what they did. John saw the website in person when he accepted the invitation from Sandia Labs to go be a part of their big group think on designing a 10,000 year warning for the place. How could you turn it down?
那这些手套很可能也带有放射性。废物隔离试点工厂的设计目的就是为了储存所有这些东西，并保护我们免受其害。WIP基地位于新墨西哥州，在沙漠腹地，大约在卡尔斯巴德以东26英里处。那是一个非常酷的地方。它让我想起了一种詹姆斯·邦德小说里魔鬼党（Spectre）或者诺博士（Dr. No）总部的感觉。因为这是一个巨大的地下设施，里面到处都是身穿连体工作服的技术人员，而且他们的工作服都是根据各自的分工用颜色分类的。约翰亲眼看到了这个网站，当时他接受了桑迪亚实验室的邀请，去参加他们的大型头脑风暴小组，为这个地方设计一个一万年的警示标志。你怎么能拒绝呢？
This was in 1991. So the workers took John into an elevator shaft and they go down about a half a mile beneath the surface. And that's where John saw these enormous caverns. They've carved out this repository in basically a salt deposit, salt deposit 200 million years old. And we think of salt as white, but this salt, for reasons I don't understand,
这是在1991年。工人们把约翰带进一个电梯井，他们向下深入地下大约半英里。就在那里，约翰看到了这些巨大的洞穴。他们在基本上是盐层的地方开凿了这个储存库，这是一个有2世纪、两亿年历史的盐层。我们认为盐是白色的，但这盐出于我不太理解的原因，
was kind of a salmon-y pink color. So the walls of this place were all crystalline with this sort of shot through with these hues of salmon and pink and orange. So it's actually quite beautiful. All this radioactive stuff will all be loaded into thousands of oil drums and packed into these caverns. And then this underground chamber will be sealed up and left alone. Years will pass and those years will become decades and those decades will become centuries. Centuries will roll into millennia.
呈现出一种类似三文鱼的粉红色。所以这个地方的四处墙壁都是结晶状的，透着这种三文鱼色、粉红色和橙色的色调。所以它实际上相当美丽。所有这些放射性的东西都将被装进数千个油桶里，并塞进这些洞穴中。然后这个地下室将被密封起来，不再管它。岁月流逝，这些年将变成几十年，几十年将变成几个世纪。几个世纪将汇入千年。
People above ground will come and go. Cultures will rise and fall. And all the while, below the surface, the salt will do what salt does with the right temperature and pressure. It will slowly creep, making that cave full of waste smaller and smaller and smaller until the salt swallows up all those oil drums, crushing them and tooming them. And so there, solidified in the Earth's crust will be these gloves and these tools and these little bits from bombs that we made all still radioactive poisonous for more than 200 000 years basically forever. Storing something dangerous safely forever is a huge design problem. In fact the jury is still
地面上的人们来来往往。文化兴衰交替。而在地表之下，盐在合适的温度和压力下，会做盐惯常做的事。它会缓慢蠕动，使那个装满废物的洞穴变得越来越小、越来越小、越来越小，直到盐吞噬掉所有的油桶，将它们压碎并掩埋。因此，那些手套、工具以及我们制造的炸弹留下的残渣，将被凝固在地壳中，它们依然具有放射性，具有毒性，长达20万年之久——基本上是永远。将危险物品安全地永久储存是一个巨大的设计难题。事实上，对于他们是否真正看清了储存问题
out on whether they saw the basics of the storage problem at all. In February of 2014, a leak was detected that exposed several workers to low levels of radiation and WIP has been closed since. The Department of Energy now predicts that it could be up to three years before WIP is fully operational again. We know these facts because we can look it up and read the news in a shared language. But the problem that John Lomborg was brought out to New Mexico to solve was not about communicating the danger of whip to people today.
的基础，目前还没有定论。2014年2月，人们发现了一处泄漏，导致几名工人受到低水平辐射，WIP此后一直处于关闭状态。能源部现在预测，WIP可能需要多达三年的时间才能完全恢复运营。我们知道这些事实，是因为我们可以通过共同的语言去查阅和阅读新闻。但是，约翰·隆博格被请到新墨西哥州去解决的问题，并不是如何向今天的人们传达WIP的危险。
He wanted to figure out how to tell people millennia from now that this place is dangerous. When John Lomborg arrived in New Mexico, he met the teammates he'd be collaborating with. There were geologists, linguists, astrophysicists. There was science fiction writer Gregory Benford. And he would be the archaeologist. This is Maureen. Maureen Kaplan.
他想弄清楚的是，该如何向数千年后的人们表明这个地方是危险的。当约翰·隆博格到达新墨西哥州时，他遇到了将与他合作的队友。那里有地质学家、语言学家、天体物理学家。还有科幻作家格雷戈里·本福德。而她将担任考古学家。这位是莫琳。莫琳·卡普兰。
An archaeologist with a consulting firm ERG. Do you remember what you thought of the people they got together, like when you first saw them? Um, it was like, oh my goodness. She was kind of starstruck. I went, John Lombard, wait a moment, aren't you the one who did the picture that went off into space in terms of trying to communicate with whoever might find Voyager? So I was impressed. After hellos and whatnot, the Sandy folks split all these Smarties into two different
咨询公司ERG的考古学家。你还记得你对他们聚在一起的人有什么看法吗，比如你第一次见到他们的时候？嗯，那种感觉就像是，哦天哪。她有点像追星族一样。我当时想，约翰·隆博格，等一下，你不是那个制作了被送入太空以尝试与任何可能发现旅行者号的生命进行交流的图片的人吗？所以我印象深刻。寒暄过后，桑迪亚的工作人员把这群聪明人分成了两组，
groups. So they'd have kind of two separate thinking processes. John was in Group B, Marine Group A. And then... And then they laid down the ground rules. They told us to assume that we're designing a warning marker for humans. Not aliens, not cyborgs. But for a human being biologically identical to us, but who's alive 500 or 5,000 or 10,000
这样他们就会有两种独立的思考过程。约翰在B组，莫琳在A组。然后……然后他们制定了基本规则。他们告诉我们要假设我们是在为人类设计一个警告标志。不是为外星人，也不是为赛博格。而是为在生物学上与我们完全相同，但生活在500年、5,000年或10,000
years from now, how can you make a message that that human will understand? And why 10,000 years? As far as I could determine, the logic seemed to be, well, if we told them to design a marker to last 250,000 years, that's clearly a ridiculous and absurd proposition. 10,000 years doesn't sound quite so crazy. So it was just pulled out of the air. In other words, even though this site is going to be radioactive for hundreds of thousands
年后的人类，你该如何制作一个能被那样的人理解的信息呢？为什么要定在一万年？据我所能了解到的，其逻辑似乎是，嗯，如果我们让他们设计一个能持续25万年的标记，那显然是一个荒谬和可笑的命题。一万年听起来似乎没那么疯狂。所以这个数字只是凭空想出来的。换句话说，尽管这个地方将具有放射性长达几十万
of years, this panel was only responsible for keeping this place sufficiently labeled for humans for the next 10,000 years. Let's get some perspective. Think about where humanity was 10,000 years ago. Back then, there was a hot new technology taking the world by storm. It was called farming. Before the agricultural revolution, humans subsisted as gatherer hunters. Biologically, we are the same people we were 10,000 years ago. Actually, that's true going back over 40,000 years. But culturally, we share almost nothing with these people.
年，但这个专家小组只负责在接下来的1万年里，为人类保持这个地方有足够的标识。让我们换个角度来看。想想1万年前人类在哪里。那时，一项风靡全球的炙手可热的新技术诞生了。它叫农业。在农业革命之前，人类靠采集和狩猎维生。从生物学上讲，我们和1万年前的人是同一种人。事实上，追溯到4万多年前也是如此。但在文化上，我们与这些人几乎没有任何共同之处。
Definitely not language. Well, no, because the linguists tell us that language changes. Language has a half-life, just like radioactive materials have a half-life. And this half-life isn't very long. Think about Shakespeare. My cousin Westmoreland, nay, my fair cousin. Alack what poverty my muse brings forth.
绝对没有共同的语言。嗯，没有，因为语言学家告诉我们语言是会变化的。语言有半衰期，就像放射性物质有半衰期一样。而且这个半衰期并不长。想想莎士比亚。我的表弟威斯特摩兰，不，我亲爱的表弟。唉，我的缪斯带来了多么贫乏的作品。
But this dotage of our generals offlows the measure. Some of the words are tough. Bully rook. Festinately. Fleshment. Clinkwant. Is that how you say that? But But you know, high schoolers can get through it. Although Shakespeare was only 400 years ago, 4% of 10,000 years. What? Go back to
但我们将军们的这种昏聩超越了限度。有些词很难懂。 Bully rook（粗鲁的家伙）。 Festinately（迅速地）。 Fleshment（初试锋芒的战功）。 Clinkwant（闪亮的饰物）。是这么读的吗？但是你知道，高中生们还是能读懂的。虽然莎士比亚生活在仅仅400年前，也就是1万年的4%。什么？再回到
Beowulf. Written in Old English. Basically incomprehensible. basically incomprehensible. L and phremedon, oft shul shaving share than a threaton. And it's like a different language. And I know you can't see this because this is radio, but trust me, it's just as confusing on the written page. You can recognize most of the letters as being part of the English alphabet, but they barely correspond
《贝奥武夫》。用古英语写成。基本上无法理解。基本上无法理解。（古英语原文略）这就像一门不同的语言。我知道你们看不到，因为这是广播，但相信我，在书页上它同样令人困惑。你可以认出大部分字母是英文字母表的一部分，但它们几乎与
with how we use those letters today. And that's from year 1000, 10% of 10,000 years. There are some languages that are very resistant to change. That is, languages that get enshrined in biblical texts, in religious texts. Latin, Hebrew, Arabic. But those aren't sure bets either. The oldest written texts go back to ancient Samaria about 4,600 years ago. And those languages are long since dead.
我们今天使用这些字母的方式不符。而这来自公元1000年，占1万年的10%。有些语言对变化的抵抗力很强。也就是说，那些被铭刻在圣经文本、宗教文本中的语言。拉丁语、希伯来语、阿拉伯语。但那些也不是万无一失的。最早的文字记录可以追溯到大约4,600年前的古代苏美尔。而那些语言早已消亡了。
And that's not even the halfway mark of our time frame. So both team A and team B at the WIP brainstorming session realized pretty quickly that every language on the planet today could be gone well before 10,000 years. And how can you start a conversation with somebody that you have no common language with? Both groups weren't sure about this. But then they thought, there's got to be something better than language. Symbols.
这甚至还不到我们时间跨度的一半。因此，WIP头脑风暴会议上的A组和B组很快都意识到，今天地球上的每一种语言都可能在1万年到来之前就消失殆尽。你又怎么能和一个没有共同语言的人展开对话呢？两组人对此都没有把握。但后来他们想，一定有什么东西比语言更好。符号。
Symbols. Pictures. There are some facial expressions which are pretty universal. Like the smiley face. Two dots for eyes, half circle for a mouth. It's happy. Yeah. And take another one. For like yuck. Symbol called Mr. Yuck.
符号。图片。有一些面部表情是相当普遍的。比如笑脸。两个点作眼睛，半个圆圈作嘴巴。代表快乐。是的。再看另一个。比如表示“真恶心”。一个叫“厌恶先生”的符号。
If you were alive in the 80s, you know this one. Mr. Yuck is mean. Mr. Yuck is green. It's a logo of a green face with squinty eyes and a stuck out tongue. The face looks like it's about to be sick. It was designed to be put on cleaning products and other household poisons to let kids know that whatever's inside is going to be horrible for you. And so thinking along those lines, they considered another logo, which they thought might be universal.
如果你在80年代生活过，你就会知道这个。“厌恶先生”很卑鄙。“厌恶先生”是绿色的。它是一个绿色脸庞的标志，有着眯缝着的眼睛和吐出来的舌头。这张脸看起来好像快要吐了。它被设计用来贴在清洁剂和其他家用毒物上，让孩子们知道里面的东西对你来说是非常可怕的。因此，沿着这个思路，他们考虑了另一个他们认为可能是普遍适用的标志。
Actually, Carl Sagan proposed it. Sagan couldn't make the panel, but he sent in a letter saying this whole marker problem was easy. You just need the right symbol. And he knew just the one. The skull and crossbones. They're Jolly Roger. Death incarnate. Well... Do you know where the skull and crossbones came from?
实际上，卡尔·萨根提出了这个建议。萨根未能出席专家小组会议，但他发来了一封信，称这个标记问题很简单。你只需要正确的符号。而且他知道该用哪个。骷髅和交叉骨。也就是海盗旗（Jolly Roger）。死亡的化身。嗯……你知道骷髅和交叉骨是从哪里来的吗？
No, no, I don't. The earliest uses of it are in religious paintings and sculptures from the Middle Ages, where at the foot of the cross where Jesus is crucified, there's a skull with two bones in the shape of a cross, not an X, the shape of a cross. And it's Adam's skull. And the bones are the symbol of the resurrection. So instead of it being a symbol of death, it was a symbol of resurrection and rebirth. But fast forward a couple of centuries.
不，不，我不知道。它最早的使用是在中世纪的宗教绘画和雕塑中，在耶稣被钉上十字架的十字架底部，有一个带有两根骨头的骷髅，骨头呈十字形，不是X形，而是十字形。那是亚当的骷髅。而骨头是复活的象征。因此，它没有成为死亡的象征，而是复活和重生的象征。但快进几个世纪。
There's a lot of trade going on, merchant ships traveling to and fro. And in the ship's log, if a sailor died, the captain would put a little skull and crossbones next to his name. And a lot of the sailors came to associate that symbol with death. The rebirth part of it was kind of lost.
当时有大量的贸易活动，商船来来往往。在航海日志中，如果一个水手死了，船长会在他的名字旁边画一个小骷髅和交叉骨。许多水手开始将这个符号与死亡联系起来。重生的部分在某种程度上被遗忘了。
Fast forward another century. You've got pirates out marauding on the high seas, they've plundered other boats and stole their cargo. And along the way, some pirates realized they could use a symbol to let their targets know who they were. A branding campaign to terrify their targets into compliance.
再快进一个世纪。海盗在公海上肆虐，他们劫掠其他船只并抢夺货物。在这个过程中，一些海盗意识到他们可以使用一个符号让目标知道他们是谁。这是一场品牌推广活动，用恐惧迫使他们的目标就范。
Yeah, to make clear, we're pirates, and if you don't surrender, we're going to kill you. It's your death. But there were actually several different icons that pirates used. For example, a heart with blood dripping out of it. That was a popular pirate flag? And an even more popular symbol was an hourglass. An hourglass?
是的，为了表明我们是海盗，如果你不投降，我们就会杀了你。这是你的死期。但海盗们实际上使用过几种不同的图标。例如，一颗滴着血的心脏。那曾是一面流行的海盗旗吗？还有一个更受欢迎的符号是沙漏。沙漏？
An hourglass meant if you don't surrender in a certain amount of time, we're going to kill you all. So the hourglass for a while was the most feared pirate symbol. But then one of the logos got famous. In 1720, a pirate named Calico Jack Rackham was captured and put on trial. In the legal proceedings, it came out that two of the pirates in Calico Jack's crew were women and that one of them was pregnant with Calico Jack's child. This was the tabloid
沙漏意味着如果你在一定时间内不投降，我们就会杀死你们所有人。因此，沙漏在一段时间内是最令人恐惧的海盗符号。但后来其中一个标志出名了。1720年，一个名叫杰克·拉克姆（Calico Jack Rackham）的海盗被捕并受审。在法律诉讼中，人们发现杰克·拉克姆船上的两个海盗是女性，其中一个还怀着杰克·拉克姆的孩子。这是当时的八卦
scandal of the day and everyone in England was reading about this trial. Anyway, it just so happened that Calico Jack's symbol was the Jolly Roger, though in his case the bones were replaced with a pair of cross swords. Quick aside, the name Jolly Roger is probably an English corruption of the French Jolie Rouge or Pretty Red because the original pirate flags were red, not black. After that trial, the Skull and Crossbones started showing up on book covers. Treasure Island kind of novels. The Skoll and Crossbones was permeating culture as a symbol of danger.
丑闻，英国的每个人都在阅读关于这场审判的报道。无论如何，碰巧的是，杰克·拉克姆的标志是海盗旗，不过在她的案例中，骨头被一对交叉的剑所取代。顺便说一下，“Jolly Roger”这个名字可能是英文对法文“Jolie Rouge”（漂亮的红色）的讹传，因为最初的海盗旗是红色的，而不是黑色的。那场审判之后，骷髅和交叉骨开始出现在书皮上。《金银岛》之类的小说。骷髅和交叉骨作为危险的象征渗透到了文化中。
Jump ahead to the late 1800s, dye factories in Germany started using the Skoll and Crossbones as a symbol for poison. Half a century later, The Nazis adopted it as the symbol for their SS deathshead divisions. So the skull and crossbones came to be associated with danger and death around the world. But it didn't become universal. Not really. Think about what's happened with the skull and crossbones in the last 20, 30 years.
快进到19世纪后期，德国的染料厂开始使用骷髅和交叉骨作为毒物的象征。半个世纪后，纳粹将其用作党卫军（SS）骷髅师的标志。因此，骷髅和交叉骨在世界各地都与危险和死亡联系在一起。但它并没有变得普遍。不完全是。想想过去20、30年里骷髅和交叉骨发生了什么变化。
It's gone mainstream. Now you'll see it on kids' book bags, on onesies for infants. You can even buy water bottles with the skull and crossbones so much for the whole poison thing And the original meaning as it pertained to Adam and the resurrection is long gone The lesson that we took from this is that Symbols can change Iconographical drift happens and we haven't even touched on cultural interpretation. Like, there's a candy company in Mexico called La Catrina,
它已经主流化了。现在你会看到它在儿童的书包上、婴儿的连体衣上。你甚至可以买到印有骷髅和交叉骨的水壶，所谓的剧毒标志也就这么回事了。而且它与亚当和复活相关的最初含义早已不复存在。我们从中得到的教训是，符号是会变化的，图像学漂移会发生，而我们甚至还没谈到文化解读。比如，墨西哥有一家名为La Catrina的糖果公司，
and their logo, the logo that goes on the packaging for their sweets, is a skull. And so, to bring us back to the WIPP site in New Mexico. The two teams of smart people at WIPP realized that symbols couldn't be trusted to mean the same things over time. So, next idea? We could tell a little story using stick figures. Visual storytelling. A stick figure that like any five-year-old could draw? Yeah.
他们的标志，即印在他们糖果包装上的标志，就是一个骷髅。因此，把话题带回新墨西哥州的WIP基地。WIP的那两组聪明人意识到，随着时间的推移，不能指望符号始终保持相同的含义。那么，下一个主意是什么？我们可以用简笔画讲一个小故事。视觉叙事。像任何五岁小孩都能画出的简笔画？对。
Circle on top, a trunk, two arms and two legs. Why? Well, there are two things that seem to be universal in human art. One is a stick figure. And you find them all drawn on the walls of the caves and the cave paintings that are 25,000 years old, which by the way may be the only piece of graphic art surviving for more than 10,000 years. That is art from which we can draw meaning.
上面一个圆圈，一个躯干，两只胳膊和两条腿。为什么？嗯，人类艺术中似乎有两个普遍存在的元素。一个是简笔画。你在25,000年前的洞穴墙壁和洞穴壁画上都可以找到它们，顺便说一句，这可能是唯一能存活超过10,000年的平面艺术。那是我们可以从中汲取意义的艺术。
And John says there's another convention that is universal. A sequence of events. First this happened, then this happened, and then this happened. So like a narrative, a story. A narrative, a storyboard, a comic strip. You just find it everywhere. And in fact, you could even define a symbol
约翰说还有另一个普遍存在的惯例。一系列事件。先发生这个，然后发生那个，接着又发生那个。就像叙事一样，一个故事。叙事、故事板、连环画。你到处都能找到它们。事实上，你甚至可以定义一个符号
using stick figures. Check it out. Let's do a simple comic strip. So first frame, you put the small child. And the child is in front of a small plant, a sapling. Second frame, that child is a little bit bigger now, and the sapling behind him has grown a little bit. Then next to the child is a barrel, and on that barrel is the symbol for radiation, the
通过使用简笔画。看这个。让我们做一个简单的连环画。所以第一格，你放一个小孩子。孩子面前有一株小植物，一棵树苗。第二格，那个孩子现在大了一点了，他身后的树苗也长高了一点。然后孩子旁边是一个桶，桶上有辐射符号，
trefoil symbol. And the child is touching that barrel. Go to the third frame, you got a full grown big old tree, you got a child that is now an adult, a human being, except the person is lying on the ground, presumably dead, X's over their eyes, frowny mouth, and the barrel now with the trefoil symbol is open. And so clearly the idea is don't touch anything with the trefoil
三叶形符号。而孩子正在触摸那个桶。进入第三格，你有一棵长成的大树，你有一个现在已经是成年人的人类，除了这个人躺在地上，大概已经死了，眼睛上有叉号，嘴呈苦相，而带有三叶形符号的桶现在是打开的。很显然，这个想法是：不要碰任何带有三叶形符号的东西，
symbol or at least not a barrel. Of course if you read it from right to left then it's a totally different story. The old guy who is sick discovers the fountain of youth and he's reborn. Okay all is not lost. Maybe you could use arrows. Arrows are universal or maybe you could situate the various comic scripts in a sequence that you can only see sequentially based on how they're arranged in a space. So I don't know, maybe it's possible to create a universally recognizable warning sign that way. But really, regardless of whatever symbol we're trying to come up with or whatever story
或者至少不要碰桶。当然，如果你从右往左读，那就是一个完全不同的故事了。生病的老家伙发现了青春之泉并重生了。好吧，并非无可救药。也许你可以用箭头。箭头是通用的，或者你可以把各种连环画按顺序排列，让人只能根据它们在空间中的排列顺序来顺序观看。所以，我不知道，也许有可能以这种方式创建一个普遍可识别的警告标志。但说实话，不管我们试图想出什么符号，或者我们试图讲什么故事，
that we're trying to tell, can we actually build something, make something, like a physical, tangible thing that can last 10,000 years? The brainstormers at WIPP thought about building something from solid gold. Well, what's going to happen? They're going to get stolen. Maureen Kaplan, the archaeologist, her group realized the same thing. Metals were going to get recycled. So no bronze, no aluminum. That basically leaves you with rocks. And rocks can erode.
我们真的能建造某样东西，制造某样东西，比如一个能够持续10,000年的实体、有形的东西吗？WIP的头脑风暴者考虑用纯金建造某样东西。嗯，结果会怎样？它们会被偷走。考古学家莫琳·卡普兰和她的团队意识到同样的事情。金属会被回收利用。所以没有青铜，没有铝。这基本上只剩下岩石了。而岩石是会侵蚀的。
And who knows, a giant monolith could be useful to some future desert person. You could just tip it over on its side and then you have a foundation for your house. Here is the critical moment where all the obvious choices have been exhausted. Language, symbols, and storyboards weren't going to cut it. And here's where plans for the website start getting really wacky. There was this one guy in Maureen's group named Mike Brill. Mike Brill was a landscape architect. And an artist. Brill has since passed away, but Maureen remembers in their group, Brill had this revelation. You don't actually need to transmit information into the future.
谁知道呢，一个巨大的独石可能会对未来的某个沙漠居民有用。你只要把它推倒，你就有盖房子的地基了。这是关键时刻，所有显而易见的选择都已耗尽。语言、符号和故事板都行不通。正是在这里，网站的计划开始变得非常古怪。莫琳组里有一个叫迈克·布里尔（Mike Brill）的人。迈克·布里尔是一位景观设计师。还是一位艺术家。布里尔后来去世了，但莫琳记得在他们的团队中，布里尔有了这样一个顿悟。你实际上不需要向未来传递信息。
All you need to do is make somebody scared of being in that place. He was trying to sculpt the landscape such that it in itself gave a warning to people who were coming there. And he was thinking on a massive scale, on a scale greater than I'd ever imagined. Like one drawing, which Mike called the landscape of thorns, a drawing of these huge needles. Sharp, pointed, angular. Jetting up from the ground. The earth itself became a cactus. Make the land itself ominous and impassable.
你所需要做的只是让某人害怕呆在那个地方。他试图塑造景观，使其本身就能向来到那里的人发出警告。他的构想规模宏大，超出了我以往的想象。就像一幅画，迈克称之为“荆棘景观”，画中是这些巨大的针状物。锋利、尖锐、有棱有角。从地面喷涌而出。大地本身变成了一片仙长掌。让土地本身变得险恶而无法通行。
But. The last thing you want to do is draw people to see this incredible work of art. You've got to see this thing. It's a half mile of these giant spikes. What the hell is it? So somebody builds a hotel for them to stay in and they decide to dig a well for water and there you are. You've just caused exactly what you're trying to avoid. When all was said and done, both groups submitted their proposals, but Sandia Labs found most of the ideas a little too pie in the sky.
但是。你最不想做的事就是吸引人们来看这件不可思议的艺术品。你必须去看看这个东西。有一半英里的巨型尖刺。这到底是什么鬼东西？于是有人为他们建造了一家酒店供他们住宿，他们决定打口井取水，然后你就到了。你正好造成了你极力想要避免的结果。说到底，两组人都提交了各自的提案，但桑迪亚实验室发现大多数想法都有点不切实际。
Here's Roger Nelson, the chief scientist at the Department of Energy's Carlsbad field office, which owns and operates WIP. If we build any markers, they need to be constructed at a reasonable cost because it's just not right to ask real current generations of real people today to sacrifice through their tax dollars or whatever, to invest in protecting a hypothetical intruder into some very far future from a risk for which there's likely no harm to the result. In fact, the panel that met to figure out the WIP marker system was actually not the first instance
这位是罗杰·纳尔逊（Roger Nelson），能源部卡尔斯巴德现场办公室的首席科学家，该办公室拥有并运营WIP。如果我们建造任何标记，它们都需要以合理的成本建造，因为要求当今的真实人们通过他们的税收或其他方式做出牺牲，来投资保护未来某个非常遥远的未知入侵者，使其免受可能根本不会造成伤害的风险，这是不对的。事实上，开会研究WIP标记系统的专家小组并不是第一次
of thinkers being brought together to consider how to communicate the dangers of nuclear waste over time. There was one such meeting in 1981 for the Yucca Mountain Project, which was eventually scrapped. And the Yucca Mountain Project had probably the craziest idea proposed. And even though it was never suggested for WIP, it's become the 99 PI in-house favorite method of communicating with people 10,000 years in the future. In fact, there's probably a reason why we're doing this story at all.
召集思想家来探讨如何随着时间的推移传达核废料危险的先例。1981年，针对尤卡山项目（Yucca Mountain Project）曾召开过这样一次会议，该项目最终被取消了。尤卡山项目提出的可能是最疯狂的想法。尽管它从未被提议用于WIP，但它已经成为99%隐形节目组内部与1万年后的未来人交流的最爱方法。事实上，我们做这个故事可能是有原因的。
Call it the RayCat solution. My hands-down favorite approach came from these two European philosophers, Francois Bastide and Paulo Fabry. It goes like this. The two of them got thinking that the most durable thing that humanity has ever made is culture. Religion, folklore, belief systems, sure they morph over time but an essential message can get pulled through. And so Bastid and Fabri said, here's what we're gonna do. We're gonna
称之为“雷猫解决方案”（RayCat solution）。我最喜欢的绝对是不二之选的方法来自这两位欧洲哲学家，弗朗索瓦·巴斯蒂德（Francois Bastide）和保罗·法布里（Paulo Fabry）。它是这样的。他们两个开始思考，人类制造的最持久的东西是文化。宗教、民间传说、信仰体系，当然它们会随着时间而变形，但核心信息是可以被传递下来的。因此巴斯蒂德和法布里说，我们要这么做。我们将
genetically engineer a species of cat that changes color in the presence of radiation. Then we'd release them out into the wild to become feline Geiger counters. And that's just step number one. Step number two, we will create an entire system of folklore about these cats. So we will sing songs about them, we will draw pictures of them, we will tell stories about them. And like any good story, there's a moral. That when you see the cats turn color, run far, far away. Withers our crops and it burns our skin and it turns our lives dark gone So don't change color
基因改造一种猫，这种猫在有辐射的情况下会变色。然后我们将它们放生到野外，让它们成为活体盖革计数器。这只是第一步。第二步，我们将围绕这些猫创造一套完整的民间传说。所以我们要唱关于它们的歌，我们要画关于它们的像，我们要讲述关于它们的故事。就像任何好故事一样，其中蕴含着一个道德教训。当看到猫变色时，赶快逃得远远的。它枯萎了我们的庄稼，它灼伤了我们的皮肤，它让我们的生活陷入黑暗。所以不要变色，
Little kitty don't flash your eyes So don't change color Little kitty don't flash your eyes Once this Ray Cat folklore becomes embedded into our culture, the knowledge it contains can evolve with us even as our language shifts. Ten thousand years from now these songs and these stories may sound incomprehensible to us, but as long as they communicate this these stories may sound incomprehensible to us, but as long as they communicate this idea, that it's not safe to be where the cats change
小猫咪，不要闪烁你的眼睛。所以不要变色，小猫咪，不要闪烁你的眼睛。一旦这种雷猫民间传说融入我们的文化，其中包含的知识就会随着我们一起进化，即使我们的语言发生变化。一万年后，这些歌曲和故事对我们来说可能听起来难以理解，但只要它们传达了这种理念——猫变色的地方不安全——我们就完成了我们的工作。愿雷猫保佑我们安全。
colors, we will have done our job. May the ray cats keep us safe. The plan that Sandia Labs decided to move forward with does not involve ray cats, sadly, or a landscape of thorns. It doesn't even involve the skull and crossbones. The conceptual design includes a big berm 30 feet high earthen construction around the footprint of the repository. That's Roger Nelson again, the chief scientist overseeing WIP. At the end of the day, the powers at be decided to go with solutions that the panelists had pretty much cast aside. They're marking the area with large granite monuments.
桑迪亚实验室决定推进的计划并不包含雷猫，遗憾的是，也没有荆棘景观。它甚至不包含骷髅和交叉骨。概念设计包括一个围绕储存库占地30英尺高的巨大土石护堤。这位又是罗杰·纳尔逊，监督WIP的首席科学家。最终，当权者决定采用专家小组几乎已经抛弃的解决方案。他们正在用大型花岗岩纪念碑来标记这个区域。
Large granite monuments at each corner and in the middle and several buried libraries. There will be information in seven languages, the six languages of the UN, Arabic, Chinese, English, French, Russian, Spanish, and also Navajo. Because it's the most prevalent indigenous language of the area. The plan is still being finalized. But keep in mind, we're talking about protecting people that our great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great grandkids will never know. We have a duty to warn them. We have a responsibility to mark the area. After a certain point, I started wondering, like, isn't this just a bit ridiculous? While I was researching the story, I read about this town called Talabast, a small,
每个角、中间以及几个埋地图书馆都有大型花岗岩纪念碑。将有七种语言的信息，即联合国六种官方语言：阿拉伯语、中文、英语、法语、俄语、西班牙语，以及纳瓦霍语。因为它是该地区最盛行的土著语言。该计划仍在最终敲定中。但请记住，我们谈论的是保护那些我们的曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾孙永远不会认识的人。我们有义务警告他们。我们有责任标记这个区域。在某一点之后，我开始琢磨，这难道不是有点荒谬吗？在研究这个故事时，我读到了一个叫做塔拉瓦斯特（Talavast）的小镇，这是一个位于
predominantly African-American community about an hour and a half south of Tampa, Florida. In the 1960s, a beryllium processing plant was set up in the middle of town. The plant manufactured components for nuclear bombs and also built pieces of the Hubble Space Telescope. Anyway, it turned out that this plant was never very good about dealing with its waste. Beryllium dust and other toxins made their way into the town's groundwater. And Talivast had always gotten its water from shallow wells. Residents started noticing that a lot of people were getting diagnosed with cancer and other
佛罗里达州坦帕市以南约一个半小时路程的小型、主要由非裔美国人组成的社区。20世纪60年代，镇中心建立了一家铍加工厂。该工厂生产核武器组件，还制造了哈勃太空望远镜的部件。无论如何，事实证明这家工厂在处理废物方面一直不怎么靠谱。铍尘和其他毒素进入了该镇的地下水。而塔拉瓦斯特一直从浅水井中获取水源。居民们开始注意到许多人被诊断出患有癌症和其他
diseases including Borreliosis, which you get from exposure to Borrelium. Talavest filed a lawsuit against the company that owns the plant, Lockheed Martin, and Lockheed spent years dragging out the lawsuit. Now the reason I bring this up is because Lockheed Martin happens to be the parent company of Sandia National Labs, the corporation that runs the website over in New Mexico. And this case at Talivast is hardly unique. There are literally thousands of towns across the United
疾病，包括莱姆病（Borreliosis），这是由于接触铍（Borrelium）引起的。塔拉瓦斯特对拥有该工厂的公司洛克希德·马丁公司提起诉讼，而洛克希德公司花了数年时间拖延诉讼。我提出这一点的原因是，洛克希德·马丁公司恰好是桑迪亚国家实验室的母公司，而桑迪亚国家实验室正是运营新墨西哥州网站的公司。塔拉瓦斯特的这个案子绝非个例。美国各地有成千上万个城镇，
States, many of them low income or communities of color that have become contaminated in similar ways. And so the 10,000 year whip marker system feels really noble, but maybe a little misguided. I am all for taking care of people 10,000 years in the future. But I think the best way to do that is to start taking care of people that are alive today. That way there might be humans in 10,000 years. And cats. That story was reported by Matt Kielte and produced by Olive Samuel Greenspan back in 2014.
其中许多是低收入或有色人种社区，它们都以类似的方式受到了污染。因此，一万年的WIP标记系统感觉非常高尚，但也可能有点被误导了。我完全支持照顾一万年后的未来人。但我认为最好的方法是开始照顾今天活著的人。这样一万年后才可能有人类。还有猫。这个故事是由马特·基尔特（Matt Kielte）报道的，并由奥利夫·塞缪尔·格林斯潘（Olive Samuel Greenspan）于2014年制作。
Special thanks to Rob Moss, Matt Stroud, Jordan Oppener, Evan Luick, Steve Lerner, and Emperor X, aka Chad Matheny, for composing the original song, Don't Change Color Kitty. 99% Invisible was reported this week by Gillian Jacobs and produced and edited by Vivian Le, mixed by Martin Gonzalez, music by Swan Real, fact checking by Graham Hayesha. Cathy Toove is our executive producer, Kurt Kohlstedt is the digital director, Delaney Haunt is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Berube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson,
特别感谢罗布·莫斯（Rob Moss）、马特·斯特劳德（Matt Stroud）、乔丹·奥普纳（Jordan Oppener）、埃文·鲁里克（Evan Luick）、史蒂夫·勒纳（Steve Lerner）以及X皇帝（Emperor X），即查德·马泰尼（Chad Matheny），为原创歌曲《不要变色，小猫咪》（Don't Change Color Kitty）作曲。本周的《99%隐形》（99% Invisible）由吉莉安·雅各布斯（Gillian Jacobs）报道，维维安·勒（Vivian Le）制作和剪辑，马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martin Gonzalez）混音，音乐由斯旺·里尔（Swan Real）创作，格雷厄姆·海沙（Graham Hayesha）核实事实。凯茜·图夫（Cathy Toove）是我们的执行制作人，库尔特·科尔斯特(Kurt Kohlstedt)是数字总监，德兰尼·亨特(Delaney Haunt)是我们的高级编辑。团队其他成员包括克里斯·贝鲁布（Chris Berube）、杰森·德莱昂（Jason DeLeon）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、
Lasha Madon, Joe Rosenberg, Gabriella Gladme, Kelly Prime, Jacob Maldonado-Medina, Sarah Bake, Nina Potuck, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% Invisible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful Uptown, Oakland, California. Home to the Oakland Roots Soccer Club, of which I'm a proud community owner, other teams may come and go. But the Roots are Oakland first, always.
拉沙·马顿（Lasha Madon）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、加布里埃拉·格拉德梅（Gabriella Gladme）、凯利·普莱姆（Kelly Prime）、雅各布·马尔多纳多-麦地那（Jacob Maldonado-Medina）、莎拉·贝克（Sarah Bake）、妮娜·波图克（Nina Potuck），以及我，罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。《99%隐形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客大家庭的一员，现在总部位于奥克兰美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市潘多拉大楼以北六个街区。
You can find us on all the usual social media sites, as well as our new Discord server. It's really great over there, I encourage you to join. There's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这里是奥克兰根基足球俱乐部（Oakland Roots Soccer Club）的所在地，我很自豪能成为它的社区所有者，其他球队可能会来来去去。但根基队永远是奥克兰的第一支球队。你可以在所有常规社交媒体网站以及我们的新Discord服务器上找到我们。那里的氛围真的很棒，我鼓励你加入。在99PI.org上有通往该链接以及99PI每一期过往剧集的链接。谢谢。本期节目尚无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。